[Applause]
on the new book and so the new book is
called have I told you this already so
why the title do you tell a lot of
stories over and over again yes
um that's one of the main reasons I I
guess it's um sort of a nod to the age I
am which is an age where I've had such
good friends for so long that in some
cases I can't remember if I've told them
the story already if they were there
with me when it happened if they know
the most recent version like it is it's
sort of just about
um having known somebody a really long
time and and just it came out of
pandemic times of thinking of kind of
the stories that have meant a lot to me
in my life many of them told to me by by
my dad and and sort of what's my version
of that like what are my sort of
greatest hits I guess yeah did you grow
up wanting to be a writer were you
always into it I grew up a really
serious reader and um that was kind of a
gift given to me by my dad who was a
great Storyteller of his stories from
his own life but also would read to me
every night so I could read when I was
really little I actually skipped
kindergarten because the teacher left
the room is the 70s and um she came back
smoke break and I was reading a book to
the class and she wondered if I'd
memorized it or if I actually could
could read so reading was really
important and storytelling I think is
how I ever got interested in being an
actor it's just like I would imagine
that I was the panda bear or whatever I
don't know again what story this is but
um so writing kind of feels like a
natural extension of that I think it's
like a way for me to tell a story
um on my own you know without needing a
production necessarily Yeah in our
imagination I say it all the time
there's no budget with your imagination
so it's like really cool it's like a
movie or TV thing you can really create
whatever you want that's why I love
books I love
um fiction and this is non-fiction but
in this one in particular
um kind of the titles come to me and
then I write the story around it so it's
been interesting as I have more
experience and
um as I write more it's almost like I
don't know if you have this with music
but it's I was like I do titles like
that by the way really yeah I write I
literally have one of my next seven
called skip this part and I was like I
just want to skip this part of this
whole devastating situation and so I
wrote the whole song around I do that as
well so I I think it's like that's how
your brain tells a story right and and
so that's some of these there's one
called boobs of the 90s for example
um that that just kind of came to me and
I was like what is this about and it's
kind of about
it's about how things have changed since
the 90s but my boobs were stuck in the
same place I don't know you have to buy
the books but um
but in the way that I think probably you
know the song you think of the idea and
then the rest of the song comes to you
that's what this is because there's the
theme yeah yes boobs
you boobs so much
[Music]
[Applause]